are are you optimistic or pessimistic
about the future I'm cautiously P
pessimistic how was that I I'm I'm
worried quite worried I mean look at
this two-tiered system of justice you
got Donald Trump let's just take the
January 6 indictment he's being indicted
because essentially his lawyers made the
argument that the vice president has
more than ceremonial duties on the first
week following an election the same
argument Democrats make made after 2000
when they tried to decertify Florida
same argument Democrats made after 2004
when they tried to desertify Ohio there
were 30 house uh Democrats plus Barbara
Boxer including Benny Thompson chair of
the January 6th Insurrection commit all
joining to decertify Ohio because they
argued that the Debo voting machine had
been tampered with where have you heard
that before 2016 they challenged more
States and Donald Trump did after for
2020 nobody accused them of being
election deniers nobody prosecuted them
and their lawyers were not facing
disbarment this is just Madness and it
seems to me where's the ACLU when you
need them where's where's the left and
and and this Hunter Biden Joe Biden
stuff uh Woodward Bernstein I'm young
enough to remember that in in the 70s
they they went nuts over Richard Nixon
and Nixon didn't do it for for for greed
uh he was trying to cover up the um
Breakin of of wargate because he had a
bunch of uh bunch of his AIDS who got
involved in that and Daniel ellsburg
psychiatrist right minor things these
Wen huge and uh Woodward Woodward uh is
still there he's still at the Washington
Post he's an executive there and Carl
Bernstein is still around where are
these guys nobody seems to care it I'm
I'm I'm blowing away where the country
is right now I really am half the
country believes the other other half is
evil yeah you're absolutely right and
young people when I say young people if
you're in college right now you probably
don't remember the 2000 election because
that's 23 years ago so if you're a
22-year- old college student right now
you probably don't even remember 2000
Gore pushed that case to the US Supreme
Court so you want to talk about election
Deni it took us was it 12 or 13 weeks to
actually determine the election and it
had to get to the US Supreme Court and
it wasn't Bush pushing that and Tom talk
about election denying Hillary referred
to Donald Trump for the entirety of his
presidency as illegitimate her word not
mine said the election was stolen her
word not mine Jay Johnson is Obama's DHS
secretary testified under oath that
while the Russians tried they failed to
change a single vote tally in 2016
two-thirds of Democrats believe
according to ugv poll that the Russians
quote change votal close quote to elect
Donald Trump zero evidence that changed
any a greater percentage of Democrats
believe 2016 was stolen then we fail
that way by 2020 nobody calls him
election deniers yeah and all such a
double standard yeah and all Hillary in
the DNC got was like a
$170,000 slap on the wrist for the whole
Russian collusion dossier Hillary and
the DNC paid for the steel dossier and
the F FEC finded them uh because they
characterize it as a legal expense
Donald Trump characterized the stormy
Daniel thing as a legal expense he's
facing criminal charges by the by the
Manhattan da it's outrageous what do
what do you think is gonna end up
happening in Trump nothing okay so I
think he's going to get I think he's
probably going to get nominated uh if he
gets nominated he'll get elected and
he'll pardon himself but wait a minute
you also said that Larry Elder on Trump
uh you said this a few months ago I'm
not sure he's electable you said he's
nominat but he's not electable so your
positions Chang in in three months I
feel more strongly now that he can win
because of the what they've done to him
uh with the uh with all these IND so
it's changed in three months I just feel
more strongly um look he he was a great
president the economy was rocking and
rolling uh the the borders has never
been more secure we got all the judges
that we wanted up there uh buil built
the wall uh oil and gas independent uh
he was a great president and he'll
hopefully put those policies back into
place when he comes back yeah I feel
more strongly now than I did before how
will he pivot to the center you know
they I think Nixon was famously said
that you know you run to the right then
you pivot to the center same with the
Democrats run to the left right so I I
fully agree that Trump is going to be
the nominee and I also despite popular
opinion I think sleepy Joe is also going
to be the guy I think we're going to see
what happens during that debate I I
think he will will be the guy if he can
fog up a mirror he'll be the guy and if
he's not it'll be C so when oh God
forbid no I mean I I don't know why
people feel that somehow somebody else
is going to sneak in like that even
Gavin Newsome just the other day said
yeah uh I'm not going to run in 2024 uh
KLA Harris is uh is next in line and
I've been saying that for months he
played Koy because look the strongest
part of the democratic base are black
voters and even more strong are black
female voters and they love KLA Harris
and they feel that when we make fun of
her cackle it's both sexist and racist
they feel that Joe Biden's given her
thankless tasks like getting to the
bottom of of uh illegal immigration uh
they feel she's been mistreated and if
she is perceived as having been drop
kicked for a white dude like Gavin Nome
or mayor Pete black women won't vote
Republican they just won't vote thereby
guaranteeing whoever nominee is he or
she will win so they can't afford to do
that and Gavin nsome knows that that's
why he never never announced but let's
stay on Trump because I think K is a
non-factor but that's my opinion I know
what you just said but how could she be
a non-factor if Joe Biden can't if Joe
Biden can get across the Finish Line as
soon as he gets across Finish Line he
hands over the Baton to her and she
could run I just don't think she's
electable but I want to stay on Trump if
you don't mind um so when he's going to
Pivot to the sener stuck they're stuck
with her that's my I don't think you
understand what you you understand what
he's saying right I understand complely
he's saying he's going to win then he's
going to give it to her so she can stay
for eight years it's not an anointment
like it's going to be an election no but
what he's saying
is it over this is important about the
gender and identity uh uh POC party
which is a Democratic party their Dei
score is very high when when cly bur got
behind Joe Biden after uh uh Bernie sers
won of the Nevada caucuses yep for a few
days he was a front runner they were
scared to death he's a self-described
uh Democrat socialist and they they knew
he couldn't win not controllable so
James kurn gets off the sideline on the
eve of the South Carolina primary
endorses Biden they all fell in line he
extracted a promise from Biden that his
first nominee would be a black female
his vice president black female for a
time it looked like Diane Feinstein
might not finish out her term in
California and Gavin Newson publicly
said if she can't finish it out I will
nominate a black female they're all
about Black this the year of the black
female and they got a black female now
next in line after Biden if she's drop
kick for a white person black women will
be livid and they will not vote they
won't vote Republican Le W vote well I
think I think a lot of black people are
going to black women are going to be
upset because I don't think K's
electable but how Will trump pivot to
the center and actually win the election
because you just hit the nail on the
head as as old and decrepit as Joe Biden
is with all the lingering issues with
with Trump which I think are a lot of uh
the media and the justice department
basically
doing this um how will he pivot to the
center and win over independent voters
or even moderate Democrats I think what
he's going to do is not run with a
female I'm not I'm not quite sure who
it'll be but Kim Reynolds maybe of Iowa
or Christy Nome of South Dakota uh but
or maybe even Cary Lake but it's GNA
it's gonna be a female you think that's
that's how he's going to Pivot I can't
think of anything else he can do I mean
we all know what he's about what can he
say now he can't reinvent himself he is
who he is he is what he is so I think
what he can do though is nominate a
female what about a strong black man
like Larry Elder as the VP talk to me
about that Larry I've told people if my
phone rings and Trump's on the other end
I won't let it go to
voicemail I think your phone's ringing
right now Larry but but he's not going
to do that I I that would not be the
smart move I can't bring California to
him yeah uh I'm not in the swing state
and he doesn't need to have another man
he needs he needs to have a female
unfortunately that's the way politics
works and Larry not to go conspiracy
theory because Adam loves when I I'm a
coincidence there you know when they say
I'm not going to go here they're going
right there going right there say it's
not about the money it's about M about
the money when the cop says there's
nothing to see here there's definely to
see I signed a $300 million contract for
10 years but it's not about the money
but but lar do because I mean as you saw
with the left with 2016 where Hillary
from weaponizing the FBI and everything
is against Trump Adam made a good point
that he is obviously it's obvious he's
he's the front runner do you think the
left has anything up their sleeves I'm
just saying in the sense that we keep
getting warmed about pandemic tools
coming from fouchi from from Biden
everybody keeps saying hey they're
warning us they're testing out the the
the new vaccine this new variant to test
do you think because mind you election
year Donald Trump is probably going down
as one of the best statistic uh policy
presidents ever all of a sudden an
election year a couple months before
Larry a virus comes out of a lab that we
own and they still have zero
accountability because it's still racist
it wasn't just that also 51 former
intelligent officials signed a letter
saying that the hunter Biden laptop
story had all the earmarks of Russian
disinformation 2 and a half year
collusion thing using coid to change the
rules in Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania
y uh who knows what they're going to do
exact that's but but they're going to do
something something something is up to
something is happening to keep because
apparently the game plan of keeping Joe
Biden in the basement works so here's my
here's my question for you you you you
don't sound optimistic you said you're
cautiously pessimistic right uh I'm I'm
not sure if the voices of any party to
be cautiously pessimistic encourage that
party to want to go above and beyond
it's kind of like it's halftime you're
down three touchdowns and the coach
comes in and says guys I'm pessimistic
we're going to lose today it's going to
be a pretty bad loss and uh you're all
going to be you know embarrassed at the
end of it it's going to be terrible and
then boom you know Patriots come out
from down 283 against the Falcons and
they win the Super Bowl Jets won last
night without
without but what but what I'm saying
what I'm saying to you is you know to
say cautiously pessimistic and to sound
like everything is bad everything is
ugly everything is this everything is
that great well what solution do you
have for the rich Republicans of the
right for the Christian conservatives
for the Libertarians that are also not
happy about what's going on about the
business owners about the guys that have
the money what what should be the
solution long term well that's
that's why I am running I am running
because I I'm an America first guy
believe that taxes are too too high
regulation is too much uh we need to
secure the borders we need to get need
to get back to energy Independence uh I
was a very happy camper when Donald
Trump was uh was president and um we
need to work real hard to make sure if
he's a nominee he gets back in so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here